this tractor is essential for Haider and
worst Farm here in Sudan's Jazeera State
he says he inherited it from his father
and he uses it to dig canals to irrigate
his crops or till the soil but he says
the Machinery is so old it's not as
efficient as it used to be
I've had some equipment for 20 years
some has been with me for 25. we
actually use equipment that has been
refurbished we can't afford to buy new
equipment if something breaks we weld it
there's no investment in the projects to
afford modern equipment
haider's Farm is part of the Jazeera
agricultural project it's a 2.2 million
acre agricultural scheme that's one of
the largest of its type in the world it
was established nearly a century ago and
was once regarded as the Bread Basket of
Sudan crops like sorghum cotton and
wheat were harvested not just for local
consumption but also for export now only
about half of the land is being farmed
the input for Harvest is not always
affordable to Farmers and the seeds
aren't always the best the land is there
the water for irrigation is there but
there is need to rehabilitate the
facilities of the project
more than a hundred and thirty thousand
Farmers work on the project that's
managed by the government but Farmers
say the government hasn't invested
enough most of the Machinery around here
has been in use for years Farmers say a
failure to modernize the Jazeera scheme
has led to a decline in production of
crops in the country for example 75
percent of the country's reach was once
harvested here now most is imported
other crops have also been affected
affecting market prices and reducing the
availability of food in the country
the world food program says a third of
Sudan's 43 million people don't have
enough food partly because they can't
afford it the organization says
investing in agriculture in places like
Jazeera project will help the country
and others but Sudan's political crisis
May deter investment
the fertile land that you see behind me
projects like this well you can not only
feed Sudan you can help feed the whole
world and so that's why we're here we've
got to resolve some of the issues in
Sudan so we can move forward bringing
private sector investors investors that
will work with smallholder Farmers
maximize Harvest yield production and we
solve food security around the world
Hyder says he hopes to see more
investment in the project that would
help him not only get modern equipment
and increase production but also grow
enough crops so that Jazeera project can
once again export food from Sudan Hebrew
Morgan Al Jazeera Jazeera state